>> EXCUSE ME, MR. BRO, SIR, DO
YOU HAVE TIME TO TALK ABOUT THE
ENVIRONMENT?
>> DREAMS.
CLIMATE CHANGE.
>> OH, NO.
>> WHAT YOU MEAN NO?
>> I DON'T BELIEVE IN THAT
GARBAGE.
>> BAG THIS FOOL, MAN.
>> TREES.
I BE LOVING THESE TREES.
>> TREES, I BE LOVING THESE
TREES.
>> MAKE THEM WORK.
>> MAKING A TREE.
I PLANT ALL THESE TREES.
>> PUMPING THAT OG.
CAN'T GET A JOB BECAUSE YOU
SMOKE TOO MUCH WEED BUT YOU ARE
FULL OF THC.
>> HEY, YOU TALKING ABOUT THE
WRONG TREES, MAN.
>> HMM?
>> WE ARE TALKING ABOUT
ENVIRONMENTAL TREES LIKE THE
PLANET.
>> OH.
>> COOL.
>> FOCUS WORDS TOWARDS THAT.
>> ALL RIGHT.
>> KNOW WHAT I'M SAYING?
>> OKAY.
>> SO WHENEVER YOU ARE READY.
>> GIVE ME A SECOND.
I WORKED HARD ON THE OTHER
VERSE.
WHY ARE YOU STRESSED UP WE ARE
PLAYING OURSELVES.
>> I CAME TO WORK.
>> HOW ABOUT SOMETHING LIKE, I
PUT MY GREEN THUMB IN A BROWN
HOLE.
>> ALL RIGHT.
I DON'T KNOW WHICH HOLE BUT I
LOOIC THAT.
>> SOMETHING SOMETHING ABOUT
CLEAN COAL.
>> LET'S GO.
>> JUST TRY AND CHANGE THE WORLD
LIKE AL GORE.
ALMOST PRESIDENT AL GORE.
JUST TRYING TO CHANGE THE WORLD
LIKE AL GORE.
♪ SHOULD HAVE BEEN PRESIDENT AL
GORE.
AL GORE.
>> AND I LOVE THE TREES, TREES.
LOVING THESE TREES.
>> LOVING THESE TREES.
♪ TREES ♪
♪ WAIT FOR A MINUTE ♪
TREES TAKE A LONG TIME.
DO I GOT BAD DIRT?
I DON'T KNOW.
SOMEBODY TELL ME.
>> HEY, TREE DOCTOR, TELL THIS
GUY CLIMATE CHANGE IS FOR REAL.
>> I'M A MEDICAL DOCTOR YOU
CAN'T KEEP KIDNAPPING PEOPLE.
>> NO, WHAT YOU NEED TO BE DOING
IS SAVING TREES LIVES.
>> SPREAD THE WORD.
>> FELLOWS, I GET IT AND AGREE,
BUT THIS IS A TRAUMA CENTER.
>> SO YOU ARE SAYING ALL OF THIS
IN THE WRONG PLACE.
>> SO YOU DO NT HAVE ANY TREES?
>> NOT TO MENTION WE NEED TO DO
MORE THAN TREES.
TAKING PLANES LESS AND TRAINS
AND CARS MORE.
>> LIKE JOHN CANDY.
>> UNCLE BUCK.
>> AND THAT'S JUST THE TIP OF
THE ICEBERG.
>> WELL, JUST A TIP.
GOT IT, YEAH.
BUT YOU CAN AGREE THAT MORE
TREES ISN'T A BAD THING, RIGHT?
>> RIGHT?
>> RIGHT, DOCTOR?
>> I MEAN, SURE.
>> TREES, LOVING OUR TREES.
LOVING OUR TREES.
TREES, WITH PRECIOUS LEAVES.
RIGHT IN THE DIRT.
MAKING TREES.
I PLANTED ALL THESE TREES,
THAT'S A WHOLE LOT OF OXYGEN.
AL GORE.
>> TREES.